John there's a couple of films you got
coming out that you worked on Tilda
Swinton haven't you both with strict
odors it happens yes as they Jim
Jarmusch film only lovers left alive and
there's a long June hose film which is
called snow PSA yeah give us a little
bit of insight into your character in
each of those films well in snowpiercer
I play a kind of a because it's a kind
of microcosm of humanity or on a train
which is going around the globe you know
in a small Ice Age it all sounds a bit
preposterous but the fact is it's based
on a on a graphic novel which is French
graphic novel around about the ages and
so but it's so it is kind of not real in
that sense but it creates his own
reality of see learning and I'm playing
a an erstwhile leader of revolutions who
is held in great regard by the young man
who is who is leading the revolution at
the moment get all the riffraff live at
the back of the trade or the good ones
live at the front of the trailer so the
revolution
ceases through the drain
and it's he's a remarkable director yeah
so I mean that's what I do there but it
turns out that he's not actually as
admirable as he might have been
considered but and then in in the
Jarmusch film I'm playing kit Marlowe
has a vampire's aren't four hundred and
fifty years old but so I can't really
explain that children that and also cost
Tom Hiddleston's on that seriously donor
is just as I think Jesus at the height
of a guru I think is absolutely fabulous
she'd always been fabulous which is
particularly so now I think we should
got you filled really opening out and
being quite one of it she's wonderful in
snowpiercer inches fantastic we're Jim
you